こちら肇社長デフ久しぶりにシャーペンの紹介でございますちょっと最近はっちゃけた
動画ばっかりなんか俺そんな人みたいになってるけどいたって普通の大学生ですから夏
なんでちょっと今
狂ってるんですっかりで文房具紹介はされていたんでね
皆さん日今日はちょっと
会えるイトーヨーカを言って美容家これはまだ存在したことがないと思いますぜ兄さん
がある素揚げで36タイプで昔からあるんですけどこれはねー
やばいえんまぁあと後々離さ0天候の下んっ
ここが柔らかいんで本体はこんな感じでございまーす男性見た目がこんなんだからさ
かっこいいんだよなぜ今さらこれを紹介するかというとこれはね多分俺買ったけど普通
に
これから使いますこの図リムタイプにはね昔から変な思い入れがあるんですよ
こんな感じですこれが体がいいからこんなんだけどめっちゃ細いんですよこんな感じ
です俺もちょっとわかんないんだとか
科学的な話じゃないし俺が正しいかとかわかんないんだけど俺の頭なジジイがね
俺の友達とか知り合いとか周りの人は
この喋っ使ってる奴はみんなねー
頭が良かった勉強せずにいいところに行く女の子とか
本当に東大でやってたああ
仲良い友達とかもねこれを使ってたんですよ食べて勉強2が自分だよ
自分の勉強することが大事なんだけどさそんなにじゃこれ使ってる人はみんな頭いい
みたいなことだって本当にまあそういうもんなんだと思ってねさて変えた身体魂良く
なるわけじゃないよ買ってからが大事だけど
ね効率が良くなるっていうか俺も生えばござい
雨戸生きるかなと思って実際買ったら
成績が下がりました車便通が本当にねあれなんだよ
人それぞれに合う合わないがあるから自分にアンシャーペンを見つけて下さいおすすめ
のシャーペンを教えて下さいって言っても僕に会う車ベース9お勧めできないんで
いろんな左眄使ってね
エイ
バセットくるやつを見つけるのが一番いいと思います
ただ一定つがねこれを使って勉強してたからさ他社便がすべてじゃないんだけどね結局
何喋っじゃないんだよな
そんな長はな気持ちでもねだよってちょっとシャーペンチャナさん勉強を共にする3
一番身近な存在である
信頼できるよとさペイントしたよね下記ウオッチとかあんまり言うまでもないです軸は
ぶれないする僕も知らせし者ペラ州の逸品だと思います
ただ僕みたいに手が大きい人はちょっと
しづらいかなそんなに鉛筆よりかは太いから全然いけると思うけど
手がつけられないか効率が良くなるんかな止まらずに勉強してだから彼はじゃーん